mais celia l'avenir dans les tables des
cafés et ça va pas mais tu ne touches
pas c'est toi la tâche avec ta tête
il est dès qu'ils voient vous les ont
les yeux qui piquent bonjour ça je
n'avais pas eu dans la tâche n'est pour
l'entretien ouais et basse et non pas
même c'est bon c'est le fils de monsieur
traoré que je compte sur vous pour que
ça se passe bien ça fait mal c'est pas
parce que tu es pistonné que tu vas te
la couler douce ici on est là pour
travailler
les bonhommes du bow wow elle est bonne
pour casser les couilles
il s'appelle nous nous c'est quoi ça
c'est chez non non c'est renoir c'est
bon salon c'est ce que disait ma grand
mère tu vas avec le blanc c'est que ne
trouve pas autrement
mais j'étais super zhang a déclaré löw
6.1 moby dick morris colosse que skiable
faut que tu fais la passe et je peux
bien me la gent normande bien sûr que ce
soir je vais lui faire la misère un mois
d'habitude je couche plus vite mais ça
marche pas maintenant je vais être sur
mes sentiments mais c'est bon les
sentiments se susurre pour tous les deux
je suis content tu veux un bon conseil
d'ami pour pouvoir coucher avec à
l'avant à moi change de meuf
tu vas lui sauter dessus direct moi je
protège et si elle est fragile aussi
fragile
tu passeras jupette une paire vers des
montagnards est là tu portes des moutons
sur tes épaules je vais lui faire de
cadeau à maintenant je vais d'amour
d'amour et d'eau
je suis pas une fille facile va falloir
te battre l'essentiel c'est que ce soit
un garçon rien
oui
jamais tu mets le voile gecas des
lacunes étaient dégueulasses à manches
désolé mais le voile ça fait peur à la
france et moi je français à belle et bum
la guilde française